[music playing]
NARRATOR: Valley of the
Kings, Luxor, Egypt.
Opposite from the famous
burial chamber of King Tut
is a small crypt, KV55.
It is known only by a number,
because even though it was
discovered over a
century ago, no one is
certain who was buried there.
This is at KV55 in
the Valley of the Kings
away from the public
eye, most egyptologists
and archaeologists are baffled
and have a lot of questions--
very little was known
about this tomb, OK.
[music playing]
One of the most common features
of all the tombs in the Valley
of the Kings is the amount of
wall paintings on the tombs,
explaining everything
and telling the world
that this is the
tomb of that king,
and this is how
great that king is.
But look at this tomb--
completely empty.
NARRATOR: In 1907,
archaeologists allegedly found
an ominous curse on
the wall, assuring that
whoever occupied
this tomb would not
return in a subsequent life.
When they first
opened his tomb,
they found little
remains of hieroglyphics
on this wall that
says, "The evil one
should not live again."
NARRATOR: Inside,
archaeologists found
a coffin with the remains
of a mummified body
with an elongated head.
The right side of its
skull was smashed in.
But perhaps the most
striking feature of the tomb
is that unlike all other
tombs in the valley,
it was not built to
keep grave robbers out.
It was built specifically
to keep someone
or something trapped inside.
This is the burial
chamber of the tomb.
Right here is exactly where the
sarcophagus would have gone.
And to north, south, east,
and west of the sarcophagus
where the four magical
cardinal blocks
that protects the tomb
from any intruders.
[music playing]
This is a part of some of
the magical blocks that
surrounded the sarcophagus.
These rocks and every
other tomb had inscriptions
on the outside, on the
side facing the world,
so it protects the tomb from
the world except for this tomb.
This tomb, the rocks
had hieroglyphics
with the inscriptions
on the inside,
as if they intentionally wanted
to protect the outside world
from the contents of this tomb.
NARRATOR: The ancient
Egyptians were strong believers
in reincarnation and
even had a specific name
for the part of the individual
that attaches itself
from the body after death.
They referred to it as ba.
The ba is the personality.
The ba is the character.
Every human had a ba.
And the ba is the
part they believed
moves out and is
reincarnated in another life,
another living human.
NARRATOR: Ancient
astronaut theorists
suggest that the concept of
what the Egyptians referred
to as the ba or the detachment
of the spirit from the body
has been depicted in
artwork throughout history.